le pistolet à impulsions électriques
pour remplacer la technique de
l'étranglement c'est ce pourquoi devrait
opter le ministère de l'intérieur a
encore les informations du parisien cela
intervient après l'annonce en ce début
de semaine de christophe castaner de
bagnères ladite la technique de
l'étranglement sur fond de débat autour
des violences policières des commandes
aurait même déjà été envoyés pour
équiper plus largement les forces de
police et pour en parler en direct avec
nous rocco contento secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité sgp
police bonjour alors un pistolet à
impulsion électrique un quart ont mis
fin la technique de l'étranglement est
ce que c'est une alternative que vous
pensez judicieuse écoutez sap est une
alternative judicieuse sûr qu'on
regrette c'est que le ministre de
l'intérieur lorsqu'il nous a retiré le
royal contraintes de la clé
d'étranglement dans son dans ses
annonces n'est pas immédiatement parlé
de cette solution alternative
alors pour nous le teaser le pistolet à
impulsion électrique n'est pas forcément
la recette miracle
je vous rappelle que l'utilisation du
taser l'utilisation du taser n'est pas
enseignée dans les écoles de police donc
il faudra faire un gros effort de
formation par rapport à ça il faudra les
budgets conséquents pour avoir une
dotation individuelles qui représente
plusieurs millions d'euros
approximativement
et puis vous savez aussi une chose qui
est très importante c'est une arme
intermédiaire de neutralisation distant
ciel qui peut s'avérer dangereuse par
rapport aux personnes qui sont cardiaque
donc voila tout individu récalcitrants
qui vous rappelera de se soumettre à un
contrôle de police ou et
l'interpellation n'aura pas son bulletin
de santé sur lui donc voilà on voudrait
pas non plus tomber dans ce qu'on a déjà
vécu à savoir une intervention où on va
tâcher la personne qui refuse de cesser
interpellés parce qu'elle a commis un
crime ou un délit est ensuite qu'elle
décède suite à une crise cardiaque
ça sera encore qu'on sera encore taxé de
violences policières néanmoins puisque
la clé d'étranglement n'est plus actuel
et que nous nous disions que c'était une
bonne technique
je rappelle qu'il ya eu 3 millions
d'interpellations l'année dernière en
france et que dans la majorité des cas
de plus de 90
9 % ça s'est bien passé eh bien on nous
retire de bras contre interne le
pistolet à impulsions électriques
effectivement peut être une solution
alternative à voir de toute manière nous
les choses sont clarifiées demain
puisque nos instances supérieures
syndicale rencontre en bilatéral le
militant l'intérieur monsieur castaner
alors justement quelle va être la teneur
de cette réunion à l'écouté je voudrais
pas anticipé mais déjà manifestés la
colère des policiers puisque deux à des
annonces publiques de l'intérieur ont
été très très mal perçu par la majorité
des collègues d'ailleurs ça vous a pas
échappé que le premier ministre dans
demain à apaiser les choses en envoyant
des signaux positifs envers la police
nationale
mais je dirais que le mal a été fait par
monsieur castaner parce que on nous
retire nombre de contraintes qu'ont le
placage ventrale est aussi sur la
sellette
moi j'ai interrogé comment on va faire
lorsqu'on aura un individu de 100 kg
sous cet empire de stupéfiants ou
complètement alcoolisées cas combien
écrit mais qui n'aura pas si c'est
interpellé il faudra bien tout de même
que force reste à la loi et pour le mot
note de ce que nous avons aussi pas
causé du tout c'est la suspicion de
racisme avéré qui en termes de droit n'a
aucun fondement moi j'appelle ça un bel
oxymore
et c'est une présomption de culpabilité
pour les policiers alors que nous devons
être des présumés innocents comme chaque
citoyen dans ce pays
alors après je voudrais revenir avec
vous sur deux aspects justement sur la
technique du placage ventrale ne semble
que christophe castaner est resté évasif
sur cette technique pour l'instant elle
n'est pas encore interdit et justement
il a été prouvé démontré qu'elle était
dangereuse une proposition de loi avait
même été faits maison par la france
insoumise pour l'interdire en france car
cette pratique est déjà interdite dans
d'autres pays car dangereuse pourquoi en
france elle est maintenue comme ça mais
écoutez elle est maintenue parce que
c'est une technique efficace lorsqu'elle
est bien pratique et ça vous permet
d'amener un individu au sol et de le
menotter
après encore faut-il bien appliqué cette
technique
voilà toute une histoire de
une formation je rappelle que
quotidiennement les plaquages montereau
sont pratiqués lors d'interprétation
entre guillemets houleuse où un problème
est que dans la majorité
les choses se passent correctement bien
bon on n'est pas étonné sur ce que
revendique la france insoumise parce que
voilà la france à soubise et pense que
l'on vit dans un monde de bisounours et
voudra mettre un peu pourquoi pas
désarmer la police nationale donc voilà
à partir de là où il faut faire très
attention c'est que les moyens de
contrainte
il existe pour la police nationale on a
la force légitime et nous sommes les
seuls à pouvoir l'employé d'une manière
mesurée et si on ne retire tous nos
moyens de contrainte
je voudrais que le sait la direction
générale de la police nationale ou les
listes nous explique comment on
procédera aux interpellations des
individus qui seront sous l'empiré de
stupéfiants ou complètement alcoolisées
qui ne mourront pas se laisser
interpeller
oui alors dans d'autres pays où la
technique du placage ventrale et est
interdite c'est bien évidemment pas la
france
insoumise 1 qui a demandé à interdire
cette technique pour le racisme si je
comprends bien ce que vous dites ce que
vous avez déjà dit ça si un policier est
soupçonné de racisme
vous plaidez pour qu'il ne soit pas
suspendu et donc qu'il reste en fonction
jusqu'aux conclusions jusqu'aux
conclusions de l'enquêté c'est oui on
vit dans un état de droit tout de même
un policier n'est pas un sous citoyen
c'est un citoyen comme tout le monde
pour mettre quelqu'un en examen pour le
suspendre vous rappelle que quand on
suspend un policier déjà il et il est
d'un traitement faut donc un salaire
amputé toutes ces primes 30 conscient de
son salaire on suspend pas sur une
suspicion on suspend sur des faits
avérés mais c'est les notions de droits
élémentaires il ya un code pénal et le
code de procédure pénale dans ce pays il
faut l'appliquer
nous avons droit nous aussi comme chaque
citoyen de ce pays allaient présomption
d'innocence est alors christophe
castaner est revenu justement sur cette
suspicion et sur cette suspension
il a bien précisé que la suspension
administrative des policiers soupçonné
de racisme d'intervenir dès lors
que le soupçon est suffisamment fort
pour qu'ils aient des poursuites
judiciaires on parle pas de simples
soupçons c'est dès lors où il ya une ces
deux heures où une enquête qui est
ouverte alors fermé l'adriatique et à la
dialectique est importante
un soupçon n'est pas un fait avéré
n'importe quelle avance la porte quel
avocat vous dira on ne suspend pas on ne
prend pas des mesures disciplinaires sur
un soupçon savez moi je fais soupçonné
mon voisin d'avoir commis une infraction
je vais pas pour l'en pour autant la
terre aller l'interpeller
j'attendrai une preuve donc à dessus des
faits avérés
oui nous sommes d'accord mais des
soupçons dont n'importe quel avocat vous
dira que ce qu'a dit le ministre en
parlant de soupçons avérés
en droit c'est ça n'a aucun fondement
monsieur contento on n'a plus beaucoup
de temps désolé merci d'avoir été avait
la préférence